من اسبوع مثل اليوم كان العالم على موعد
مع كارثه طبيعيه ما كان احد متحضر لها ولا
يمكن اصلا الواحد يكون جاهز للشيء مثل كده
نتكلم طبعا عن زلزال تركيا وسوريا عدد
القتلات تجاوز 37 الف قتيل ومئات الالاف
من الجرحى والحصيله بتزيد يوم بعد يوم
والامم المتحده بتتوقع موحه زياده عاديه
بل بتتوقع تضاعف عدد الضحايا ومع انه من
يوم الخميس والكل بيقول خلاص فرص العثور
على ناجين تقريبا بتختفي لكن عكس التوقعات
والطبيعه والعلم ووفق اراده رب العالمين
وبس في ناس لسه بتطلع عايشه من تحت
الانقاض رغم انهم بدون اكل او شرب او
اكسجين او درجات او درجات الحراره لازم
نذكر انها 0 او تحت الصفر مسنين واطفال
وشباب لسه بيطلعوا عايشين
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر